[Music]
thank you all for being here tonight
uh dry your eyes and please join me in
welcoming the director
don't make me go hannah marks
[Applause]
hi hannah
and from the film please join me in
welcoming mia isaac
[Applause]
and the one and only john cho
[Applause]
congratulations on the film all of you
and and thank you so much for being here
tonight um thank you for having us of
course um
so
it's such a fantastic film i i'm a
little bit dazed because i just watched
it again sitting it's fantastic to watch
with an audience and um i'm literally
just had the experience of these guys i
mean to start up hannah i'd love for you
to talk about how
so i think with your first two films you
wrote or co-wrote
your other features um and this one you
did not write could you talk about how
you came to do this what attracted you
to the script and and how you found it
i had a general meeting with peter saraf
who's the producer and i was a big fan
of his because he did little miss
sunshine and adaptation so many
wonderful movies
and he sent me the script just thinking
i would be right for it and
i fell in love with it i loved the the
father-daughter story at the center of
it i thought it was so beautiful and
and thankfully they were all open to
such collaboration that i did get to do
a little bit of writing on it and get to
play with these two and do some improv
so there was still a way into it for me
that felt like writing even though it
wasn't my story
and when did you come on the project
when did that start
oh gosh i don't know all the years blend
together
it was definitely before the well before
the pandemic so i mean how many years
ago did i meet you john like i think it
was 2019
that i that we met early 2019
so it was probably about a year before
that um well so i immediately want to
ask about the the cast and how how you
found these two because i mean the
chemistry between both of you and your
performances are so beautiful i can't
imagine this film with with anyone else
in it how can you talk about the process
of casting it and
how how you landed on these two yeah
it's funny there were many iterations of
this movie before i came on even because
vera herbert our screenwriter wrote this
when she was in college i think back in
2012 and so this movie has had other
directors other actors and i just feel
so fortunate that we were the ones that
got to do it i've been a john fan for a
long time he's so terrific i i think yes
thank you
i just i feel like every time i ever saw
him in something it was a totally
different genre and he just excelled in
every genre and that's really what i
love about actors the ones that are as
versatile as he is
and then we auditioned i think 400 girls
for wally and
mia made a self tape from her home in
atlanta georgia and she was just
terrific and they did a chemistry read
on zoom and
it i mean it's so hard to have chemistry
on zoom and they just
nailed it so
i i didn't get to meet mia until we were
in new zealand
it was pretty wild i met her right
before
wow amazing okay mia i just want to say
you're so fantastic in this and i've
never seen you on screen before and to
me one of the most exciting things in
going to a film is discovering a new
actor and i just feel like we're going
to be seeing you and lots of great
things and it was just thank you yeah um
but how did you so i know you've done
some work prior to this but this is like
your first really big role am i am i
correct yeah i mean i really hadn't done
anything really i'd done a couple of
small things like commercials and things
like that but i'd been
um auditioning and i just hadn't really
booked anything and so um
this was
a little
intimidating for me just because it felt
scary it was my first time on a big film
set and so i'm really scary
no i think hannah was was the one who
actually made it less scary so
but how did the project come to you
um i did my first self tape at the end
of 2020 um and i think the the whole
audition process for me
um was over the course of like a month
or almost like a month and a half and um
i just remember being so nervous because
there would be these gaps of like a week
and a half between call back and call
back and i never
i could never i never remembered caring
about something so much because i read
the script and i really just like
it resonated with me emotionally and i
loved it so much and
when you love something and you care
about something that makes you scared
and so um i just really wanted to book
it because i i loved the story and i
loved wall-e and i loved john and hannah
with every meeting and so
um i'm glad it all worked out but at
first you didn't have the script and we
did a zoom and i was like so when wally
dies and she was like what
wally you guys she's like you mean
max uh so that was i felt sad that i
spoiled it for her
so do you remember what uh
did she get particular scenes to
audition eventually um do you what were
the first scenes that you i auditioned
with the
max and wally fight scene in the kitchen
at the beginning of the movie and the
um
the scene where
max and wally are at the
cajun restaurant in new orleans after
max gone to the fight was originally a
longer scene
[Music]
of us just kind of arguing about him
cheating on my mom
which later got cut but it was it was
that was my self tape
you also did the scene with glenn at the
soccer field right
i forgot about that because i didn't do
it with john
and i had to pretend like my mom was a
cute teenage boy
she did great
[Laughter]
wow
the life of an actor
[Laughter]
so and john how did you get involved in
the project and what what drew you to it
um the
it came through my agents
i read it um
and it was a movie that i wanted to see
um and
i also
there is a kind of um
it feels like a movie in some ways
from another era to me you know a very
intimate
family portrait
and um it's something that i feel like
is being made less of and um
uh so i love the story and then i met
hannah who um just was really impressive
and
i also just felt like oh i i this is
a weird job in the sense that she's
going to have to sell my story
and wally's story very convincingly and
i felt that she was going to be able to
do that
and i felt very safe and
and um
she felt very sharp
so i wanted to follow her
yeah that's great
um
i would love to hear about sort of
from all three of you
when you were in production
well first of all i'm curious if there
was any rehearsal period because the
relationship that you two have is so
full and feels very lived in i'm just
curious was that did you have a racial
period or was this like an indie film
where you're just on set and shooting
and finding it in the moment i mean not
yeah not really we because we shot in
new zealand so we were in quarantine
and then uh and then we just had to
shoot yeah so we did a little bit if i
may if i may reflect a little bit on
those audition scenes um
those were
uh two argument scenes and i think
mia really drove the kind of
relationship that max and wally were
going to have in my mind because i saw
some other actors
and what distinguished her read was that
in this fight
in those those two scenes were of them
bickering
on the surface but underneath that
the way she was playing it it was very
plain that they were very
loving towards one another and that was
underneath all of that
and i picked up on her cues
and that really was the thing that i
kept returning to that there was this
history
of the two of them who had lost the same
person
and that they had helped each other
through that and that history was
apparent in this reading
and we just went to that place
i remember we did rehearse the
father-daughter dance
and
that was so moving to me because it was
the first time i got to see them hold
each other and i wasn't expecting
how the physicality would really change
the emotion it just really took me back
so nice and they were still getting to
know each other it was very very sweet
just met we met like the night before
like the day before
the day before you filmed that scene
before we were rehearsed so we had we we
had like
a week yeah
that is a beautiful scene
that's the first one where i'm like oh
boy okay here we go
it's a tuffy that was a toughy yeah
yeah um
so hannah i'm curious
you know you
tonally the film is so interesting
because it's it's a drama it's it's this
intimate family drama there's that sense
of history of shared loss and the loving
relationship but there's also so much
humor in it and i'm curious if could you
talk about tonally how you wove
the humor throughout and balance those
you know the the lighter moments with
everything that's going on
and and the
his knowledge of what's happening to him
doesn't like crush the movie into some
very dark space like the way you balance
those is really
really remarkable
thank you uh i remember really not
wanting it to be too depressing
especially with such a dark ending
so i think we all spent a lot of time
collaborating on the idea of like where
could there be levity where there isn't
like we added some things together like
the pet lizard because mia has a pet
lizard in real life so we added that and
um i think right before we filmed i
wrote the the dorky dad rap that john
does in it when he's trying to convince
her to go on the road so just things
like that we were always searching for
the levity and jerry
very geriatric yes jerry the car
actually came from the fact that
in new zealand left-hand drive cars are
illegal and the loophole is if you get a
vintage car of a certain year then you
can have it
so
max went from having like a very uh safe
toyota modern toyota to having a
wagoneer so just things like that just
always looking for where there could be
humor and letting the characters drive
that
i think it feels we would have coming
from characters when we would do these
driving scenes hannah would
we
go for a take on one direction and when
we were resetting
she'd say let's roll
and then
she would have the wacky talk we'd have
the walkie-talkie in the cup holder
and then she'd say let's improv
something
play 20 questions or whatever so it was
she was uh
you know guiding us those those moments
uh
some of those moments ended up in the
film and i think they're very effective
because they're very real and
you know it's when you have an actor 20
questions though with mia because we
realize that none of us have the same
references because we're all different
remember when it took you we played 20
questions and it took you like two hours
to figure out i was saying timothy
chalamet
well i remember john's first one was
carrot top and you were like what who's
carrot top
um
so it was you see the sophistication
divide
carrot top timothy
it was it was just a tough game for the
three of us in particular and then i was
so tempted to chime in on the walkie but
then i'm ruining the takes yeah right uh
but it was really fun we had a great
time carrot top also won best actor at
the indie spirit awards yes
many times
[Laughter]
wow
um oh and then the nude beach i mean
it's hard to that i mean
that's
a bunch of schlongs yeah exactly that's
just funny i didn't have to do anything
there
but it's i mean it really is kind of a
tight rope like
i
i'm still just kind of marveling at it
you know you
like that moment is very funny but it's
also the moment where she's just found
out what's really going on so it's like
emotionally heightened and you're
laughing at the same time and you really
pull that off
thank you what i loved about the writing
of that scene is the opening is is funny
and charming and
intriguing in how vera wrote it and then
when you come back to it later it's very
much not funny and i thought that was a
nice nice spin on it
um
did you find
aside from the moments of improvisation
did you find the the the movie that you
were making this is a really dumb
question because the answer is probably
always yes but once you cast these two
and saw what was unfolding between them
just as actors working together did the
film change in ways that you didn't
expect did that you know either tonally
or just the quality of the relationship
shift the movie at all
from what was on the page or what you
thought it was going to be like
well there's always surprises but
actually no because i think they were so
in tune with the script and the
characters so that they were really um
really fast you guys were just in the
tone of it it just felt right you guys
felt like a father and daughter so i
don't know with my first movie it was
originally meant to be a comedy and then
we kind of cast more dramatic actors and
then that movie wildly shifted
whereas this one i think you guys were
already in the zone and the tone that we
anticipated but of course i was always
surprised by their beautiful work
i mean
john doing the falsetto
was not expected for me
yeah
um
so mia going back to so you you audition
on zoom you get the part
um
actually what was that like when you
found out you got the phone
story
i mean i was
well when i the day that i found out
they kind of tricked me because they
made it seem like it was another
audition and so
i i had been straightening my hair for
every audition and so like
i found out like an hour before i was
like okay i have to get on zoom for this
like last round of auditions and my
mom's like straightening my hair and i'm
like oh my god and so i get on the zoom
and i'm freaking out because i think
it's like one last audition and then
hannah's hannah says um
oh do you have your passport are you
ready to come to new zealand and i was
like yeah if you'll have me i'm like not
so not ready um and then she kept acting
like you mean if i get the job and i'm
like i'm trying to tell you you got the
part she kept like saying things that
weren't really saying that i got it um i
remember you were like do you have your
passport and i thought she would be like
i booked the part but instead she was
like i mean i yes i think i have my
passport and then you you were like you
were like will your friends miss you in
new zealand and i was like well if i get
this part then maybe
i was like mia you got the part and then
when
[Laughter]
and then eventually when she spelled it
out for me um as soon as she said it my
parents kind of like ran in because they
were listening at the door
um and they ran in on zoom and were like
my whole family was around me just like
her siblings they all did a happy dance
and i recorded the whole thing of course
i have the video it's pretty great wow
your lizard is in the background
so then so you get the part you go to
new zealand i'm i'm
want to keep this directed to you at
first but
this is your first big role
you're acting opposite joncho the
cameras are rolling like what was sort
of how did you find your feet as an
actor
um was it pretty just seamless like you
you were prepared you you loved the
script you were working with good people
um i mean i i definitely think um
before i got there i was really really
nervous because it felt like
i hadn't met any of these people in
person before and it was all over zoom
so it almost felt like
imposter syndrome a little bit because
it was like you guys all liked me on
zoom until you meet me in person like i
was like i don't know if you're gonna
like me you don't waste all this money
on me
um but when i got there i was just like
i was really grateful for hannah and
john because even though it was
this big
intimidating in ways of a project it
felt really intimate and comfortable and
they were really nurturing and they made
it such a safe environment for me
and there was never a moment where i
felt like
i didn't have anybody to talk to or turn
to
or i never felt stupid for asking dumb
questions or
yeah it was just it was a really great
great experience
that's that's wonderful
john i loved your performance in this
and i feel like i mean i've always liked
you as an actor but i feel like in the
last few years you're doing
really beautiful work in like very
different types of parts and you know
from columbus to searching to after
party to like there's a real range to
your work that is comedic and dramatic
and in this role it felt so
uh
like relaxed and unforced and
like the stakes are very high but you're
playing it
with with this relaxation that i just
found really thanks really fantastic
there's a lot of um
you know uh
there's a lot of luck involved in
finding the right people and you know
you were making a movie about family
and i was very
lucky to have hannah and mia with me on
this trip and there was something about
you know there's there's there's
lots of parallels to the lives we were
living of course i'm a father myself and
i have a daughter
you know i saw that video
and
of of of mia getting the part and i said
oh look at this wonderful family i have
to honor this family as well that's like
another thing i need to do
and we were and again we were shooting
during the pandemic um in the kind of
the earlier part of the pandemic and
so these things were top of mind how
important family and friends were uh um
you know we used uh
uh mia's real life um
uh iphone videos of her as a baby in the
film so there's there was a lot of
blurring of lines and so
uh
it was a it was simple in a lot of ways
it wasn't easy but it was
straightforward in that here is this
person who i love
and i'm just going to look into her eyes
and we're going to
i really love her
[Laughter]
so much
so
some of it it was straightforward let me
put it that way yeah
that's beautiful
um hannah you are
in addition to being a writer and
director you're also you you're an actor
and have acted in lots of things i'm
curious could you talk a bit about how
uh your experience as an actor informs
your work as a director and and i'm
really curious to hear whatever you say
about sort of
what type of environment you like to
create on set and what what a hannah
mark set feels like if there is a well
i'm not one of those like cool directors
that's like let's listen to music you
know i just feel like you're there to
work so
right
i'm too stressed for that
but i mean as you can probably tell i
love a lot of close-ups and i think
that's because i fall so in love with
with the actors in the movie and i want
to see every thought so i think that
definitely informs the the process and
the acting is really always first and
foremost for me i i always find myself
on set trying to hang out with them
i'm like no i should probably talk to
camera department and some other people
um but really more so my directing has
informed my acting i think i've become a
much better actor from directing because
now i'm um
i think more collaborative and
open-minded and trusting of the director
because i as a director really need
trust from the actors for it to work so
now as an actor i'm much more trusting
and uh and just want to try anything and
take risks and um
and you know give the director lots of
options because that's what i would want
yeah that's so interesting yeah this is
an era of video village directing you
know um shouting notes from video
village and uh
and hannah's the exact opposite which
she she's
always
irl directing
she's she comes to the set and talks to
you
and it's very effective
not just to communicate her point
but
to emphasize whatever that note is
we have
uh we're communing it's a moment of
communion not just
an instruction you know what i'm saying
so
if there's any
i love when you come to me and talk to
my face
rather than from video village i try to
be as supportive and respectful as
possible and and nice because they're i
mean they're doing such beautiful work
and it's so vulnerable but i also try to
be really direct with notes because i
personally hate it as an actor when a
director gives you all this flowery
language and is talking around what they
want just drives me nuts like sometimes
simpler is better like just tell me you
want me more more mad or more or softer
you know
simple words that are actionable because
people will just talk in circles and
it'll drive you nuts trying to uh
decipher the code
right right
so john i have to ask you about this the
the karaoke scene incredible uh
rendition of passenger uh never heard it
falsetto before but it was so good
um
that's hannah
we we recorded that in a studio
obviously before you have to pre-record
the song but she's like go for it uh she
came in the vocal booth with me and and
uh
you know like a shaman was dancing for
me
pumping her fists i went to another
place man
it worked i think you did a little bit
of falsetto as a joke first and i was
like i love it so much please keep doing
it like my jaw dropped and i remember
thinking oh if my jaw's dropping wally's
jaw will drop
so please keep doing that and then i
didn't want you to feel silly so i
that's how i i had to go in there
i mean but it's a funny scene though
because it's it's what we were talking
about earlier where it's i mean it's
putting aside where the scene ends um
with your death but it's like
putting that small bit aside it's hot
it's all haha up until then
[Laughter]
it's all fun and games till the kid dies
[Laughter]
no i thought the scene was like both
funny and moving throughout because
mia your expression like you're watching
your dad with this new found like you're
getting to see a side of him that you've
never seen before and it's so real on
your face and his performance was
so it was just a beautiful moment right
comedic and moving
um john gave so many great versions of
it too while we were recording he did
like the dorky dad version he did the
full rock star version and it was just
so fun to cut together kind of create a
blend of of dad and rock star and i got
to hear it live for that actual karaoke
yeah many many times many many many
times
i'm thinking there's so many moments of
humor and even like when
max receives his diagnosis
it's one of the funniest things in the
film to me it's not haha funny but like
uh it's in the script you're like can i
sit can i say it me and my parents were
laughing so hard
i personally think that's so funny
but that's in the script it's all you
know the cues are in there and we were
just sort of
um following the tone set in the you
know in the in the script already but
there's if i look in every scene that
in every funny scene there's something
a little dark
and the reverse is true you know in
every uh dramatic scene there's a little
there's a little something funny a
little something off i mean even
in the car in florida i just love the
paper towels the sweating bit you know
um and there's something tragic it's so
tragic to me that's the most tragic
scene
in the movie to me is when the mother
doesn't come out and
and it's punctuated by this paper towel
sweating
gag
um but but that's
what makes the movie feel like life to
me
absolutely yeah then it was up to me to
edit out all the new zealand accents
[Laughter]
so i i was unaware you filmed in new
zealand was that how did that come about
john was living there and we really
wanted to make it with john and also
there were zero cases of covid there at
the time so it was a very safe place to
make a movie it's great so with the
whole thing shot there or
99.9 percent i think we went to new
orleans for a day or two to um
get like cafe dumont yeah exterior but
uh otherwise it was wow
entirely new zealand cast and crew aside
from amazing wow
um okay i've got the signal we um
i need to let you go uh but i have one
last question which is i'd love to hear
so the film premiered at tribeca this
year correct and did you get it get to
see it with an audience and sort of have
that
the
post covet or coming out of covid uh
festival experience
yeah we did it was wonderful last night
we all sat and watched the movie yeah it
was really great um
i'll share an observation
there at the screening end
at the after party what i found uh
remarkable was the number of people
who
were telling me some family incident
i have a son who had an operation
i have a father who
and
people uh felt very vulnerable um in a
good way i think uh from from the
experience and i really appreciated that
i really appreciated that
that i could share something with people
that
i had some of these people i had known
for years but i didn't know
um that these things were going on in
their lives and we're all carrying
around
something like this
maybe not at this scale you know but
thankfully
but everyone's carrying around something
like that and it was kind of a privilege
to to bear witness to to that
mia was that your first time seeing
yourself on a big screen with
yeah yeah it was my first it was my
first premieres my first time seeing
myself on a screen like that especially
with people around me i i think i
started crying like when the when the
first title card came up and um
everyone started clapping a little bit
and then i just realized that everyone
was there watching it and it was it was
really really special oh it's my first
time seeing the movie on a
screen bigger than my laptop too
so i was like huh i would have changed
that shot
i only ever saw it on 12-inch laptop
wow well congratulations thank you all
for being here and congrats on a
beautiful film thank you thank you
thank you all for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
you